oh hey everybody welcome into Market
takes I'm your host Dion rabone thank
you for joining me I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me and here with us on Market
takes and I appreciate that uh look we
are diving into the U.S retail sales
report uh for October just came out this
morning we are already seeing some
Market moves
um right now and I'm hearing a little
bit of Reverb right now so just want to
want to turn that down a little bit uh
but just want to dive into this report
talk about what the headline numbers
were of course why today's retail sales
report matters to stocks the economy
markets overall we're going to break all
that down we're going to talk about the
market reaction what we've seen from
stocks what we've seen from bonds
currencies FX what we've seen from
Commodities crypto we're going to get
into all that and how it really impacts
and what it tells us about the Outlook
going forward for the future because we
know markets are always looking forward
never looking backwards even though we
get this data that's backward looking
we're always looking forward we are also
going to talk about of course the big
picture what comes next and what this
retail sales report tells us about what
the Federal Reserve is thinking and what
they're likely to do going forward based
on the data that we've seen so we're
digging into all that today on Market on
Market takes like I said thank you so
much for joining us so look let's just
Dive Right In first off the headline
numbers that we saw retail sales grew by
1.3 percent month over month uh last
month in October and even 1.3 percent
when you strip Autos out of it when you
strip out gas you also still had a
increase of 0.9 percent uh that compared
to expectations for 1.2 percent growth
so we beat expectations just by a little
bit and expectations for 0.6 growth X
Autos again all that means is these
sales were bigger than expected and
especially when you take out Auto so
that kind of core index for what the
retail sales are showing is rising
higher than expected that's a consistent
theme that we've seen through C API the
Consumer Price Index for inflation and
what we've seen overall so we're not
seeing as much of this big pickup in
things like gasoline and food and things
like that that can be very volatile
where we're seeing the increases on
these numbers is in those core products
those things that are really at the
center or at the heart of what the
Federal Reserve is looking at and so
that makes this report a little bit more
complicated than just kicking out the
headline numbers as a lot of folks like
to do so we're going to get into just
what all those things mean one thing I
do want to do before we get too far into
this report is talk about something that
I don't think a lot of folks really talk
about when you talk about retail sales
mostly we just look at that month over
month number but I want to talk a little
bit about the year over year number and
I want to bring up a chart really
quickly just to kind of illustrate what
we've been seeing sort of longer term
when we talk about the movement on
retail sales so as you're seeing there
on your screen you had that big pickup
back in 2021 but if you look at the last
few months what we've seen on a
year-over-year basis is that trend line
kind of coming down pretty significantly
we saw that big increase to 10 percent
uh back in July and then from there
you've seen a notable kind of tick down
now we're not moving lower faster those
those reports are still showing retail
sales Rising by over eight percent each
month you have that 10 number back in
July and then you have us kind of coming
down a little bit over nine percent High
eight percent uh and and right now what
we got for October is that number just a
little bit above eight percent so uh
just about 8.4 percent that's important
because again when what we're
illustrating there and what I'm trying
to show is just the same pattern that
we're seeing on the CPI report that
overall big picture inflation report is
kind of a similar theme to what we're
seeing in retail sales you had this big
pickup a kind of winding pickup into
July and then since July you've seen the
numbers kind of start to come down
they're not coming down very fast but
they are moving in the right direction
so that's a reason to be bullish ish the
reason to be bearish or maybe worried
about the economy is because they are
not coming down very fast and like
inflation retail sales are still growing
at a very rapid pace and that's not
going to bring us to the federal
reserve's two percent Target very
quickly and that's what it's all about
so listen when we're looking at this
sales when we're looking at retail sales
just like when we're looking at any data
it's all about context and it's all
about the big picture
um also an important note we saw this
1.3 pickup that's the highest retail
sales report since February when retail
sales Rose by 3.8 percent and it comes
after zero percent growth in September
which you know is what the FED would
like to see they they don't want to see
the economy fall off a cliff but they
want to see sales not picking up keep in
mind retail sales are adjusted
seasonally but they are not adjusted for
inflation so when inflation Rises by 0.4
percent as it did in October you want to
see retail sales Rising by about that
amount or maybe even less because it
shows consumers are pulling back shows
they're not going out and spending money
when consumers don't spend companies
can't raise prices companies can't raise
the the amount that they're paying the
workers and that's what brings inflation
down so when we're seeing these numbers
retail sales picking up by 1.3 month
over month when inflation has risen by
only 0.4 percent month over month that
tells you that retail sales are rising
people are still spending money by more
than they by more than they you know
would be or more than the rate of
inflation and that's a worrisome sign
for the Federal Reserve so that's
something to definitely keep your eye on
there's a little bit of on the one hand
on the other hand with this report no
piece of no individual piece of data is
the end-all be-all but we're going to
dive into that so listen how does this
affect the outlook for inflation because
that's all anybody's been talking about
all year inflation is the word and what
matters for market and what matters for
markets this does complicate a little
bit that Peak inflation narrative that's
gotten market so excited the past few
weeks now it doesn't throw it in the
trash uh as we saw you know back in June
and July when we got those CPI reports
it was just like I'll throw that Peak
inflation report in trash what this does
do though is make things a bit more
complicated because you've got reason to
be worried and you've got reason to be
excited
um this is going to put a lot of onus
for interpreting that data on the
Federal Reserve and on fed share Jerome
Powell who we have seen have a bit of a
hawkish bias as in a bias for raising
rates higher to make sure that the crush
inflation rather than you know saying
okay well maybe we've done enough maybe
we need to keep rates where they are so
that we don't hurt the economy really
you're looking at this as is it more
important to crush inflation or more
important to keep the economy afloat fed
share Jerome Powell has said I'm all
here baby I'm all on crushing inflation
and when you get this rate right here
when you get a report like this it
suggests that inflation is not cooling
very fast but it is moving in the right
direction so I want to talk a little bit
about this peak inflation narrative
right that's what's got the market so
excited that's a lot of what's
responsible for this rally that we've
seen since the CPI report was released
back on November 10th you really have
just seen the stock market just kind of
pick up and take off especially with
those tech stocks so that CPI decline
that really signaled okay maybe the FED
can slow down on raising rates they've
raised by 75 basis Points each of the
past four meetings so and now the market
is expecting only 50 basis points
normally historically they go at 25
basis points per meeting the last four
meetings they've done three times that
so at this December meeting the hope is
hey let's slow it down let's cool it off
a little bit then once we slow it down
well that leads to stopping the rate
hikes altogether we go from 75 to 50 to
maybe 25 to zero and that's what the
market is looking all the way forward to
like I said markets always looking
forward once we stop well then we can
cut rates now then instead of keeping
rates up at this high level currently
3.75 to 4 percent on the federal funds
rate now instead of you know continuing
to raise rates or even not raising rates
keeping where we are we can start to
reduce rates and that's what's going to
boost those stock prices and that's
what's going to give Tech and crypto and
and you know oil and all those things a
big boost because it suggests that the
Federal Reserve is a tailwind and rather
than a headwind and it's going to be
helping the markets making it easier to
borrow money making it easier for
businesses to grow rather than what
they're doing right now which is
tightening the market and making all
those things more difficult
so again as we look at this one report
right how does it fit in with the other
reports that we've seen well the
Consumer Price Index and the producer
price index CPI and PPI uh basically
what customers are paying at the stores
when they're going out and buying things
and what businesses are paying when they
buy wholesale those have both shown
lower than expected readings uh for
October we also got this the GDP report
last month if you were here on Market
takes which you know I hope you were
where you should have been we talked
about that GDP report and why that was
such a strong bullish indicator for the
economy check that out if you haven't
watched that
um so this retail sales report ah those
were just really strong and really
confident for the pace of inflation
slowing down this report says okay
inflation slowing down but it could be
picking back up that core number that we
saw X Autos was high higher than
expecting that number that we saw X
Autos Annex gas was stronger than we saw
was stronger than expected and don't
forget we are starting to see a pickup
again in gas prices the amount of money
that consumers spent at gasoline
stations Rose 17 percent in October from
October 2021. so again a little bit of
on the one hand on the other hand right
if you look at that year over year
number which we threw the chart up on
screen you see inflation starting to
slow down but when you look at that
month over month number well you had
zero percent uh in September then you
had zero percent a couple months before
in July and in between that just a small
increase then you've got 1.3 percent
that's a big increase that's a little
bit of reason to worry that month over
month number showing spending still
strong which allows companies to keep
raising prices wages to keep Rising
inflation to potentially get out of
check that's a big part of how the
retail sales influence inflation and why
this report is such an important report
and one to watch this could give those
Hawks on the FED we've heard from Fed
chair Jerome Powell we've heard from fed
Governor Christopher Waller we've heard
from Kansas City fed president Esther
George they all say oh man this is bad
inflation's getting out of hand we've
got to do something we've got a bang
down with an Iron Fist and now this
report lets them say oh well you know
what yeah yeah CPI pppi blah blah blah
look at retail sales look at that one
point three percent month over month
number we got retail sales growth is
still growing at eight percent that's
something that they could say and maybe
that's a reason why they say hey we've
got to keep raising rates at a very
rapid pace and choke off inflation
before it gets out of hand so we could
be seeing and watch for this in the
speeches if you're watching what you
hear from the Federal Reserve yeah we've
heard Vice chair Leo Brainerd come out
and say maybe we've done enough maybe
it's time to chill and pump the brakes a
little bit I'm pumping the brakes uh
we've heard fed Governor Lisa Cook come
out and say something similar you could
start to see a little bit of a clash
between the Hawks and the Doves on the
Federal Reserve folks who think it's
much more important than we Crush
inflation and folks who think hey well
you know what we've got to keep some
growth going in the economy and try to
have a soft Landing maybe avoid that
recession look for a potential Clash on
what you're hearing from them of course
the chairman is the most powerful
powerful vote on that board and he seems
to be very much in the camp of we have
to crush inflation at all costs so
definitely something to watch out for
look let's look out on wsj at the market
really quickly before we get too late
I've been doing a lot of talking and I
haven't been checking the markets but
there's definitely been some movement in
the markets we've got the Dow the s p
and the Nasdaq all lower the NASDAQ down
by 0.9 percent uh we have seen stocks
kind of bounce back a little bit from
their lows this morning but we are still
moving lower on the stock market I was
watching bonds as this report came out
you've seen really across the yield
curve these prices bond prices going up
bond yields coming down folks saying
okay maybe inflation's not that bad
maybe we are getting out of the woods
especially when you look at those longer
data notes the 10-year and the 30-year
yield the seven year and the five year
also up pretty significantly on the day
when you're looking at those shorter
dated bills and and those are correlated
to expectations for what the Federal
Reserve is going to do you're seeing
just a little bit of movement you're
seeing the two year the one year up a
zero to one basis point on the price
change yield not really moving around
very much as we go to currencies the big
move that we've seen really over the
past couple weeks as stocks have grown
higher the dollar has come back down to
earth you're seeing the Euro out in
front of the dollar pretty significantly
up near about 104 to the dollar remember
the dollar was valued higher than the
Euro for quite some time for a a little
while there and now the Euros back up
pretty strongly over the dollar we're
seeing the Japanese Yen down under 140
to the dollar the the British pound uh
the UK pound or sorry yeah the British
pound up it around 118 close to 119. so
we're seeing kind of reversal of that
dollar strength as we look at into the
crypto markets it's it's still a rough
story there you've got Bitcoin down
about 2.3 percent ethereum down by 2.9
but if you're in the crypto markets you
know 2.9 percent three percent that's
not that big a move uh there's also that
story the FTX story is obviously still
Weighing on crypto markets and probably
will until we get some good news from
that market that's fundamental in nature
rather than some of these outside stuffs
like economic reports so that's the
story right now you're seeing there's
not enough reason right now I think from
this report for markets to say throw our
bullish narrative in the trash we got to
sell stocks and buy bonds you're not
necessarily seeing that you are seeing
some movement lowering yields on those
longer dated maturities 10 years 30
years but you're not seeing a major move
because this report has a little bit on
the one hand on the other end definitely
watch gas prices and watch housing
prices that's going to be big because
that's the thing that's keeping
inflation elevated we are getting some
major reports upcoming this week and
into next week on the housing market so
later today we get the nahb homebuilders
sentiment index that has been down for
10 straight months and this month is
going to be pivotal because that's now
in negative territory if the home
builders aren't feeling good they're not
going to keep building they might pull
back and say man commodity price prices
are rising we've seen the the big
increases now in natural gas things like
oil we need to not build well that means
less Supply coming to the housing market
demand is still strong you could see
prices stay high or even move a little
higher than they've been we also get uh
on Thursday that's tomorrow housing
starts and then on Friday we get
existing home sales that's the big
housing price data so make sure you're
watching those because housing has been
probably the biggest contributor to
inflation Staying High you'll want to
watch that next week the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index that
is out and you get another report on
housing new home sales that's out on
Wednesday we will be off that week
that's Thanksgiving on be with the fam I
hope you are and enjoy your time with
you and yours and then we'll come back
the following week and we are going to
hit you with that jobs report the Big
Kahuna that's the big piece of data that
comes out December 2nd we'll be right
here I hope you'll be right here with us
on Market takes anyway that's going to
do it for me I'm your host Dion rabone
this has been Market takes thank you so
much for being with us and we will do it
again with you next time I'll see you
then